hello everyone and welcome to a very
nice game uh it's round two of the
elimination round of the aim chess rapid
it's the gatakomski versus Levon arunian
this is their second game first one
ended in a drawn and while it is a very
nice one uh just a very uh very quick
announcement today I will be having a
live stream I will be having two guests
um uh phds in physics uh Andrea Dr Andre
dundovich and Dr Peter pavlovich we're
going to be discussing uh you know a lot
of cool things regarding the universe
regarding pretty much uh anything you
can think of we're gonna be discussing
it and while we're doing it there will
also be a leeches Arena going on in the
background so if you want to play it you
can play the link to the tournament will
be in the description below but if you
just want to you know enjoy some nice
conversation you can also uh join in and
be a part of it ask some questions we
will do our best to answer as many
questions as possible regarding chess um
physics the universe and pretty much
anything you can think of so it's going
to be a lot of fun uh you know uh I mean
it should be it should be fun uh so hope
you guys will enjoy it uh now that being
said uh the links are in the description
below uh let's check out this game so
katakan skin uh the second uh game
against Lavon arangan he uh wrote
something on Twitter regarding the whole
system of play but we are going to
discuss this after we check out the game
because the game itself is is pretty
beautiful we have pawned a D4 by konski
D5 by Levon and Bishop to F4 he goes for
this accelerated London system uh or or
the Mason variation nowadays it's
probably more known as the The
Accelerated London we have Pawn to C5
the steinies counter Gambit to this
system and pawn to E3 with Knight to C6
pile of on C3 and queen to B6 putting
pressure on V2 right away Queen to B3
defending and offering a queen trade and
now Pawn to C4 we have Queen back to C2
not trading and here 11 plays Bishop to
F5 it's a beautiful move that um uh gets
the queen away from the defense of the
B2 pawn and Levon of course it would
vary much enjoy capturing that opponent
A1 so Queen captures an F5 with Queen
captures and B2 and now Queen captures
on D5 asking are you maybe interested in
a free rook and while you could capture
it um it wasn't played in the game uh I
would just show it because it's a lot of
fun Queen captures now comes Queen to B5
and after Pawn to A6 now you will play
Queen captures on B7 so you have to keep
defending that Knight on B1 now after
Knight the d8 you will place well there
are many moves you could play you could
just trade captures captures but if you
want to play for the win you will play
Queen E4 guard the Knight and the game
continues this is not how it went on in
the game in the game Knight to F6 by
Lavon Queen captures on C4 and now uh
there are uh there is a game in the
database where Knights the E4 was played
and also you could consider some other
moves here like for example Queen to C1
checked so also very nice for example
King D2 Queen to B2 check if black wants
to force a draw here white can even
decide to play for the win with King to
f 3. and I have Queen side castles looks
uh I mean looks pretty wild the king is
on F3 it's actually perfectly fine Queen
to B3 and now uh uh black has to capture
The Rook otherwise he's just gonna be
down material and afterward captures you
will play G3 put your King on G2 and
black will uh struggle a bit getting
that Queen off of that A1 Square so
those are uh only some of the uh ways
you could do it but in the game Queen
captures an A1 was played immediately by
Lavon and it is now as of move 9 that we
have a completely new game so okay how
do you continue uh well it's not uh it's
not uh at all clear but the the absolute
best move is Queen to B3 in the game
Queen the B5 was played and it looks
similar uh the problem is after Queen to
B3 there is really no good way to get
that Queen off of this uh square and now
uh basically what what you are trying to
do uh is Play Bishop to D3 to have the
Knight defended and then somehow win the
black queen maybe even by playing Queen
to C2 and then maybe putting a knight on
B3 to attack the white The Black Queen
so A6 we have Bishop to D3 and now uh
well now a knight A5 would have to be
played you you need to cover that to be
three square and after Queen to C2 uh
it's very hard for black to even uh find
moves here so this this is uh much much
better for white but in the game Queen
the B5 was played instead of Queen to B3
hit okay now Levon is still in a
difficult situation but he finds a
beautiful way to get out of it pawn to
E5 attacks the bishop on F4 Bishop
captures on E5 and now uh can you figure
out why Lavon played this Pawn to E5
move it's not just uh you know a
sacrifice the speed of development it
actually has a very very specific reason
uh so feel free to pause the video and
try to find the absolute best move for
Lavon here while I give you a couple of
seconds
so for those of you who were able to do
it congratulations on uh well realizing
that only the queen is defending the
Knight on B1 and for those of you who
just want to enjoy the show it is Bishop
to B4 this is what Lavon played and make
no mistake this is not a winning move or
anything this is just the best move for
black but it's still either equal or
white is better so now you have to
defend the Knight Bishop to D3 but now
the C3 Pawn hangs so Bishop captures on
C3 check King the F1 by calm skin and
now Levon still has to figure out how to
defend his position uh he goes Queen to
B2 he offers a queen trade and defends
the B7 Pawn now comes Knight to E2 and
now Queen captures on B5 this is how uh
uh eleven trades the Queens Bishop
captures on B5 and now Bishop to A5 and
here we have Pawn to D5 it looks like a
very aggressive move but it doesn't
really work here you should just
continue developing with something like
Knight to G3 or you can even capture
front F6 but D5 allows the one this
beautiful move that uh you know uh gets
him out of all the trouble uh if there
ever any was on the board so here Queen
side castles and now you cannot uh
capture the Knight if you capture then
Rook to D1 is Checkmate so that's the
problem so here it comes he played the
bishop captures on F6 we have G captures
on F6 and now Knight eat the C3 getting
the Knight into the game Knight to E7 of
course now the Knight is hanging and now
uh Bishop to C4 we have kinked the B8
getting the king to safety and now King
to E2 we have rooked the C8 attacking
the bishop but now King to D3 and okay
Levon is up the exchanger Gata is uh
upper Pawn uh other ones has has a
double F Pawn so it's not uh you know
you can just win this by force even
though you're up material uh Rook h38
the Rooks are now beautifully placed
here they're controlling the CND file
the king is on D3 and now Bishop back to
B3 we have Pawn to A6 and The Rook to D1
we have upon the B5 and now Pawn to A3
Pawn to F5 and now Pawn to G3 so just
playing uh some useful moves here Rook
to C5 now putting real pressure on that
D5 pawn and pawn to E4 defending it with
captors captures but not with the king
the Knight captured attacking The Rook
here and The Rook just goes back Rook C
to C8 we have King to E2 now comes
Knight to the F5 and now Pawn to G4
chases away the Knight Knight to D6
Knight to F6 and now Rook the D3
uh uh sorry first H6 and then Rook to D3
uh not allowing any any infiltrating
moves via the C3 square but also just um
uh gaining more control over the entire
board uh we have rooked the C1 Levon now
says all right I will take advantage of
the back rank as you've uh just uh left
it with your Rook Knight the D2 and now
Bishop captures on D2 it's uh it's not
that complicated as you are up material
so you want to trade down King captures
and now uh sorry King captures on D2 and
now Rook to A1 goes after the pawn and
here comes he tried tried one last idea
upon the F4 we have Rook captures on A3
and pawn to H4 trying to create a pass
Pawn on the king side Butler one just
played Ponte A5 we have Pawn to H5 Ponte
A4 attacks the bishop Bishop the C2 and
here just Rook the A2 and it was in this
position on move 37 that gatakomski
resigned to the game as there really is
nothing more uh to be done here well you
could consider some moves like G G5
um yes it's a very nice move but then
Knight the C4 check and it becomes uh
very very problematic to defend for
example King C3 Rook to C8 and already I
mean there's not much uh you can do here
all sorts of nasty discoveries are
coming you will start losing uh material
and that's pretty much it uh but pretty
much all the other moves you try are are
uh insufficient for white
uh so yeah very nicely done by Lavon and
this is what komsky meant uh when he uh
posted this on Twitter okay it's pretty
much the same tweet only one is directed
at chess.com the other one is pretty
more General he said the great rapid
tournaments but a question after
grueling five hours of Chess in the
play-in uh isn't it really pushing
players Over the Edge by forcing them to
play an elimination match which just
completely erases the previous five
hours of play result because uh of
course uh kamski did not lose a single
game in the qualification for this
elimination round and now he okay Drew
one game against Lavon he lost one game
and now he is out he does not get
promoted to division one so it is pretty
harsh but it is those were the rules
before the tournament so I don't know
what do you guys guys think about this
he says once again I have to strongly
protest in the format of the play in in
the event it's just bloody ridiculous to
play a match after a grueling Swiss
tournament versus top opposition for
five hours and this match just cancels
the whole result pretty much yeah it's
basically the same tweet but uh you know
of course uh as there were 180 something
players uh of course you really want to
do well and get uh you know chosen for
that division one uh but it's a top
competition which means you have to
defeat everyone
uh so yeah that's the game I hope you
guys enjoyed it and a little bit of
extra info about the tournament today
and the
um the live stream so you know bring
some heavy questions um my guests will
do their best to answer all of them as
you know it is what they what they do uh
in life so I'm I'm sure they will enjoy
your questions uh so make them really
really difficult uh so uh that's the
game hope you guys enjoyed it uh I would
like to thank Alexandria the Rola Dean
boring him uh Maya some Yaya David
quintillion and John Anderson missing a
missing a jade there sorry about that
John uh for a contribution to my channel
thank you a lot I really appreciate it
as usual you can check to all my
previous videos here thank you for
watching and I will see you soon uh
continuing to check up on your wonderful
suggestions and whatever else happens in
the Chess World uh thank you all I will
see you soon and have an excellent rest
of your day and see you later uh in the
live stream see you soon